You probably know your blood type -- A?
B?
Universal donor?
You might even carry a card on you
so that in case of emergency,
you won’t get the wrong type of blood.
But do you know how your blood type
was actually identified in the first place?
Blood type can be determined in two ways:
forward blood grouping which detects markers
on the blood cells themselves,
And reverse blood grouping,
which detects antibodies present
in the blood plasma
Either type of test today takes a long time,
requires technical training, and can be expensive
Researchers have been working
on a new blood typing test
that is not only easy to use,
but can be done on site --
in as little as 30 seconds
A small blood sample is dropped
into the middle of the testing strip
A color change in either observation window
delivers the results
This test can perform forward
and reverse blood grouping
at the same time which gives
more confidence in the result
A similar test can also be used
to determine rare blood types
After the blood is loaded onto the disc,  the blood
spectroscopy is used to automatically
determine the blood type,
So a person doesn’t need
to interpret the color change
and the test can be done by someone
who is colorblind
Until now paper-based tests were reliant
on blood samples that had already been spun in
a centrifuge, which takes time and experience.
The introduction of these test strips
has the potential to not only
save time and money in the hospital
but in remote areas with few resources,
rapid blood typing could be done by non-trained
users and blood supplies can be stretched